Serbia's president has been meeting with
ambassadors of several countries to
discuss escalating tensions in Northern
Kosovo police have been deployed outside
the city hall in zipshan for a second
day ethnic serves have been protesting
against the election of ethnic Albanian
Mayors and blocking them from entering
their offices they don't recognize
kosovo's Independence and they boycotted
the Municipal elections last month well
let's go to Barnard Smith now who's in
Belgrade for us what did the Serbian
president have to say at the meeting
has been meeting ambassadors from the
U.S the United Kingdom France Italy
Germany and the eu's representative here
in Belgrade and he's been telling that
he's accusing the International
Community of tolerating unilateral moves
taken by the government infrastrina
Pristina the government in Kosovo and he
says that as a result there is a
decreasing number of options that could
lead to permanent peace and stability in
the region and vutic as he went on to
ask the ambassadors to ask Albin Curtis
that's the prime minister in Kosovo to
withdraw his forces and Mayors as he
says the serbs there will never accept
what he calls the occupation of that
area of Kosovo what were the reactions
from the ambassadors
so we've heard only so far from the
European Union the European Union's
foreign policy representative foreign
policy Chief excuse me Joseph Borrell he
said that the clashes that have been
happening in Kosovo in the northern part
of Kosovo been absolutely unacceptable
he said and he's urged the leaders of
Kosovo and Serbia to immediately
de-escalate the tensions and he's warned
that the EU is discussing possible
measures to be taken if the parties
continue to resist proposed steps
towards de-escalation there are frequent
outbreaks of violence in Kosovo
confrontations between the ethnic serbs
the majority in Northern Kosovo don't
accept the unilateral declaration made
by Kosovo in 2008 they've never accepted
it and there's been these outbreaks of
violence since then though what we've
just had in these last few days is
probably the most serious outbreak
there's been since Kosovo declared its
independence Rob burner thank you very
much indeed that's Vernon Smith talking
to us from Belgrade we're going to
he's the head of the research at the
cost of our Center for security studies
he's joining us now from pushtina thank
you very much indeed for being with us
as Bernard was saying there Serbian
President Alexander vutic urging Kosovo
to withdraw the ethnic Albanian Mayors
is Kosovo going to listen do you think
well the situation is very tense in the
north it's not the first time a similar
kind of situation was also in December
uh important is that now we have NATO
troops that have moved in uh and they
are providing I think a much needed uh
uh in a way space however yesterday we
saw also violent clashes between NATO
troops and the protesters and we we saw
a number of uh soldiers from the NATO uh
wounded as well as civilians it's very
important that in a way conditions in
the north uh we have some and the
violence and there's conditions for the
Syrian community in the north to return
to institutions uh that they lacked in
protests last year it's very important
that the process that we have with the
EU facilitation in Brussels the dialogue
phenomenalization of relations becomes
the platform where uh both Coastal
government and Serbian government
engaged to to resolve the the current
situation there but what is very
important to stress is that right now
the status quo is not sustainable and we
really need a sustainable solution to
the north and not just uh improvised
solutions that there is a planning place
the recent agreement signed by or not
signed technically but agreed by
President Bush's and prime minister
kurti saw all the agreement on the path
to normalization of relations between
Coastal and Serbia and the EU needs to
deliver a sequenced action plan on how
to internet disagreement because in a
larger context an EU that cannot
effectively deal uh with this kind of
situation in its own uh in a way a front
yard then it doesn't give much
confidence in the EU as an effective
actor to deal with other prices both
within Europe and and elsewhere so it's
very fundamental that the EU takes a
charge and and prevents for the further
escalation if we've seen the the level
of violence that we have seen yesterday
as you were talking about against the
NATO troops How likely is it that people
are actually prepared to listen to EU
when the tensions are clearly so high
so far we haven't had positive reactions
to uh from either side it's very
concerning that there was reports
yesterday of uh armed groups in the
north the ones who also were primarily
responsible for attacking I think the
the NATO troops
the process of or the dialogue for
normalization of relations between
Coastal Serbia started in 2011 and the
process has had some success important
success in 2013 uh we saw a process of
integration of the Serbian community in
the North to the coastal institutions uh
we had integration in the security
institutions in judicials so-called
however the recent developments have
backtracked this progress
and this has to do not just with the
elections and the mayors of course the
government of Kosovo from the Tactical
and legal perspective if has the right
to install the Mayors however that you
cannot detest the reality in the ground
in the north which is that it is a
predominantly Serbian populated area and
these mayors that were elected some is
fewer than 200 watts are not seen as
legitimate and any effort to impose
those Mayors there uh would I think
provoke for the violence so I hope that
we we see uh the leaders meet and
resolve these issues this uh current
issue in the framework of the process
dialogue but we need more sustainable
solution and for more sustainable
solution we need uh Serbia especially I
think president which is in this case to
appeal for calm and and to invite uh uh
to send the right messages so that there
is a path to which the serves living let
me ask you about what happens given the
circumstances that we're seeing at the
moment that nobody seems to be listening
to to anything that is being said by
anybody and we are seeing NATO forces
which are being targeted in in this
violence if that if nothing changes and
this car this carries on how far could
it escalate
well I think uh I I think the violence
as we saw yesterday can uh it's a
reality that will probably you know it's
not Unthinkable that it will continue
however
following the events from yesterday
there seems to be a more caution
approach from uh both leaders uh uh uh
and it is perhaps uh we won't see that
however uh it is it is essential uh uh
that the EU makes it clear that there
are consequences if the situation
continues and from what I hear is that
the EU is meeting today to discuss
exactly what these kind of consequences
might be for both Coastal and Serbia if
the violence in the north uh continues
and uh and there is no return to
dialogue
and we need stronger leadership I think
also from the US this is also always
worked in our region when we had a
unified approach from us and the EU and
right now we have seen very strong
statements coming also from the United
States uh against what happened uh in
the north of Kosovo uh it is clear I
think that what the government think
also perhaps wants is uh to have a more
sustainable path towards resolution of
the overall situation in the northern
Kosovo because it's been over uh you
know over two decades of a reality in
the north of a country that is uh you
know not uh integrated with the rest of
the country there needs to be a more
sustainable solution we appreciate you
being with us in our Jazeera so thank
you very much indeed for your time thank
you thank you